das ehrlich nicht lustig habe ein
bisschen schiss vor wurde mein name ist
luca meine lieben freunde es bereits im
titel eingeblendet denn ich mache heute
einen mtv frank und ich mache nicht
alleine sondern mit marx denn max hat
sich hier schon als einbrecher
verkleidet und wird vielleicht während
ich mit den leuten auch auf sie wie
videochat dann reinkommen und mich
überraschen und dann mal gucken die
leute glauben wir befinden uns jetzt
hier auf augen tivi und wir haben auch
hier vorne eine kamera gerettet das
heißt wenn max mich nachher aus der
szene aussieht sehen die leute und zwar
nicht mehr weil die sehen halt uns hier
und dann sind wir halt weg aber ihr seht
uns noch in der kamera so mag es gehen
da draußen wir starten jetzt hallo und
ich hier was im hintergrund ist dass die
brücke in köln nicht leisten
bist du wenn ich fragen darf
zwölf jahre alter ich hätte ich safe
älter geschätzt 16 oder so hätte ich
gesagt glaube ich welche klasse gehst du
denn da nur zwölf wird alles gut
[Musik]
man hat die folge was machst du
hallo liebe meiner oma bei der oma auf
dem sofa gerade wo ja
zum roter boden ich habe dadurch noch
nie roten fußboden gesehen was sind das
denn so fließen oder wassers teppich wie
lange bist du noch bei deiner oma heute
nicht mit ganzer familie hingefahren
oder wie schriftbild ist nicht tot
[Musik]
die leute gibt's ja gar nicht 0,0
ich dachte die sind so älter ist eine
hinter dir und ich drehe mich dann so
umwelt das habe ich auch durchgespielt
dass du dich ja leichter versteckt und
so war kein erweitern bisher hallo ja
dass du nicht diese katze was macht die
dialekte sich die ganze zeit ab oder wat
putzen sich katzen nehmen sie sich
ablenken oder was machen sie damit
jetzt kann sie sich auch noch und ihre
nutztiere katze einfach für jetzt legt
die ihre füße ab alter ich komme nicht
klar wie alt werden katzen 15 bis 20
jahre
und sie ist da die die verbringt den
ganzen tag ist damit dass sie sich
putzen wie was macht sie denn jetzt die
[Musik]
hat ja nichts zu tun streichelt die mal
hallo was geht was macht dir langweilen
ja habt ihr keine hausaufgaben oder
irgendwas zu tun
seid ihr wenn ich fragen darf
16.15 das heißt sie geht in die neunte
klasse oder zehnte sehnt in welchem
bundesland sei dir baden württemberg in
baden württemberg darf noch nicht
duschen gehen darf man nur baden bei der
gesundheit
was geht
[Musik]
onyx grad und die ist das was geht bei
dir nicht gesehen die bisherigen videos
ja oh ja mit sandra witze ja ab wann
habt die schulferien 23 oder so näher am
[Musik]
du bist schön bayern in münchen oder
mehr kann ich nicht in bayern
[Musik]
unterfranken ist dann unter fr
mach du eine runde ich mache ich sagte
zeigt das wie das geht
was geht
aber wieso trägt so zu hause eine maske
also vorbildlich natürlich recht es kann
schon sein
bitte was wir warten jetzt mal ehrlich
was ich bin alleine bei mir es kann gar
nicht sein dass niemand das ehrlich
nicht lustig also ich habe ein bisschen
schiss vorderes wurde bekommt dort einen
kurs ist jetzt okay ich bin jetzt zwar
nicht aber nicht okay du hast ja schon
ein bisschen mehr sorgen um mich machen
können das war unser versuch einer
entführung auf mtv vorzutäuschen das hat
überhaupt nicht funktioniert wenn euch
das video dennoch gefallen hat er das
gerne einen daumen hoch und dann wieder
schreibt und in die kommentare was sich
eventuell in meinem nächsten augen die
video mal machen soll
und ich hab da macht vorbei er lädt alle
einem jahr ins video hoch nein jede
woche zwei die zeiten sind vorbei
[Musik]